great to welcome back to the program
today don jeffries who's uh
incorporated um a life of experience in
different
areas into many different books
including
um survival of the richest which we
previously discussed and most
recently bulliocracy which is so
relevant
in so many ways right now it's great to
have you back on the program
oh thanks it's great to be back david so
let
i know that let's not dance around the
fact that this conversation is very
relevant
um to to donald trump but we don't have
to talk about trump at least not not
initially
what is your understanding of why
certain kids
end up uh becoming bullies
well i think that there is a and i i
cite in the book i i go there was a
study out of england that discovered
that uh basically the traits we see in
every bully are psychopathic type traits
many of them are
and unfortunately our society is ruled
largely by psychopaths and if you look
at the occupations where
psychopathic personalities are
predominant they're all the highest paid
professions
doctors lawyers ceos athletes
entertainers
clergymen uh policemen things like that
which policemen really aren't the most
successful but they have power
in terms of so uh this is when we look
at success
a successful person is indistinguishable
often from a bully
they trample on people on the way up uh
they they that's how they get their way
and as long as they win you're looking
in
the sports world certainly all the best
coaches virtually every one of the most
successful coaches have bullying
characteristics
and as long as they win that's fine if
they don't win well there's a problem
then they bring next coach on but i
think
our society pays lip service to uh
the fact that we like uh kindness or
whatever we don't i mean clearly it's a
kindness and uh empathy are looked at as
weak characteristics
where aggressiveness and being able to
confront somebody's power
especially in any kind of power these
are the qualities that we admire in
everything about our culture and
certainly the business world
uh says that now there there must be i'm
guessing
a um sort of circumstantial
aspect to this as well i mean in other
words
there must be something about the
circumstances
in which all those who might find
themselves predisposed to bullying would
find themselves in
some based on the actual reality they're
living
may become bullies and and some may not
right
sure well i and i think my the reason
why my book is different is the subtitle
says i believe it's a social hierarchy
that enables bullies i and that's why
i'm you know i
criticize the school systems especially
because this is where bullying is born
and i i don't believe they do anything
really to weed out the bullies because
they're not talking about how it's just
recent research
that has shown us in the past you know
we kind of had that stereotype well
the kid is a bully maybe he's uh his
father's beating him and he's lashing
bad at the world or
uh there's alcoholism there maybe it's a
single mother not watching him
living in a trailer park in poverty or
something that's not the case
overwhelmingly the bullies are the
popular crowd and uh
especially in the sports world and we
see the jocks bullying the
the nerdy types or whatever the goth
crowd and that's the dynamic you see in
every school system
and because of the uh the importance
that is placed on sports you know it's
ironic that these we send our kids to
school
and i you know it should be
theoretically that the kids who are most
successful
in school are those who get the best
grades because that's why you're going
there right
that's not the case very seldom are the
is the class valedictorian a popular kid
unless they also happen to be an athlete
which they could be
especially females a lot of the mean
girl types do
very well and have you know their
national honor society and things like
that
but it's because they don't want to
approach the topic of popularity because
if you have a concept of popularity
everybody knows certain kids are popular
you have to have a contrasting unpopular
there's no such thing as beauty if you
don't have ugliness to contrast it with
so i think that is the problem that
those trench coat mafia types have to
exist
in in order for the popular crowd to be
basically celebrities
in their school that i i document in the
book over and over again as you know
that
these school systems from the teacher to
the to the principals the superintendent
to the local media to law enforcement
most of the time
they always pooh-pooh the claims they
sweep them under the table your parents
will go
over and over again to the school
systems name the people who are bullying
their child
sometimes physically nothing is done
about it and a lot of times i've talked
i talked to too many parents whose kids
killed themselves they were bully sided
from it and even afterwards a lot of the
anti-bullying groups even will say no
it's more complex than that even when
they in their suicide notes
they'll say i did this because of
bullying or they'll sometimes even name
the actual bullies they still try to
sweep that under the rug and i think
that's the problem is they're not
addressing it correctly and instead they
have these kind of nonsensical
zero tolerance and no bully and those
schools as i point out
actually have more bullying in them than
the places that don't advertise that so
i think it's a complex issue but i don't
think anybody until my book
was looking at the right uh at the right
culprit here which i think is a social
hierarchy which creates and enables
bullies
to talk a little bit about the social
hierarchy i remember back
when i was in elementary school middle
school in high school where
um the the popular kids and the bullies
uh were of varied economic backgrounds
in other words you had
they were like the rich kids and poor
kids and whatever you had really kind of
a mix
more recently i've talked to a lot of
different people who work in school
systems in different parts of the
country particularly in suburban
settings now this may be different in
urban settings or rural
but what a lot of them report is that
they see that
the not necessarily the bullies but the
popular kids tend to be the richest
kids how how does that pl is that a
broader phenomenon and how does that
play into the bullying
sure i think there's a lot of crossover
between this book and my book survival
of riches which you talked about before
because it's uh
certainly wealth has its perks
everywhere and uh if you're if you're
if you're a kid who comes from wealth
you're going to dress better
you're going to have the latest
accoutrements you're going to have you
know the latest uh
ipad or whatever what your latest cell
phone
those kinds of things you're going to
have access to uh things that are going
to make you seem better and kids are
going to want to hang around with you
because maybe you live in a nicer house
maybe you have a big swimming pool in
your backyard
so of course maybe uh you know maybe
your parents will
pay for their friends to go to some
concert or whatever i mean all these
things are possible they're
whereas if a kid is is not wealthy they
might not have a cell phone or like they
have a crappy old cell phone or
something
and it's just it's like anything else
it's it's that's why looks are so
important i talk a lot about that there
is that
uh the way you can trump economics is to
be really good looking
you know a girl from the other side of
the tracks that just is really gorgeous
i don't think too many people are going
to be making fun of her economic
circumstances and uh
you know i i it's this is something i
think that again we don't we don't look
at but
i think there's a lot of cross over
there and i think that uh
not and i've i've been reminded many
times when i wrote this book it's not to
say that every popular kid i mean i
i was interviewed once by a girl said i
was a homecoming queen i said
i'm not saying everybody that is popular
is a bully but i think the vast majority
of of those bullies happen to be popular
and
and especially the cases that aren't
addressed by this
the teachers and principals and
superintendents that are not addressed
logically
i think it's because of that popularity
i'll give you a perfect example that i
said in the book uh
there was a viral video a couple years
ago uh
that where the guy went to a middle-aged
man went to his uh
his local school board meeting and he
wanted to talk about the bullying that
was going on in the local high school he
said you know i went there
you know 25 years ago or whatever it was
and he said
you know it was there then and he
pointed the finger at the school
superintendent
and he said you were the one who led the
bullying against me
you were the one who stuffed my head in
the urinal and things like and
it's shocking to see the stupid grin
this superintendent gets on his face
i mean instantly you could see he got
like a memory jolt
and he was exposed but uh he just got
well i'll tell you you know and he just
kind of laughed and
but you could see it coming back now who
knows how many other
school superintendents were bullies so
it
it's certainly in that school district
or where any will any claims of bullying
be taken seriously if the guy in charge
was a vicious bully and i think we don't
know how
many people are like that and i have a
whole section in the book where i
uh i talk about all the uh high profile
people in our society is what from you
know actors to uh
you know actors the entertainment world
the ceos just people that have
politicians and it's astonishing how
many of them
were the overwhelming majority were
popular in school
and so it's just if you look at it like
i think the group bowling for soup
had a song called high school never ends
and i think
it that's kind of the way it is where
that crowd
not all of them and they're bill gates
people out there of course they're
outliers but
they're if you look at i mean people
don't know woody allen for instance the
quintessential nerd was actually a great
high school baseball
basketball player so you know if you can
get some rosie o'donnell was her
homecoming queen
so it's not a lot of times we'll look at
it and people don't realize and so i
think they're already
this the social hierarchy was very good
to them
and just certainly the fortune 500 comes
all the overwhelming majority of these
people went to the high profile
fraternities which i talk about in the
book that's where out of high school you
go to college
and it's the fraternities and sororities
the greek life that's where you see the
next step in building those clicks
and of course that turns into business
business clicks because those people go
into high-profile jobs and they're
fraternity brothers and again it
it it's this kind of corruption that we
i write about everywhere else we see
these kind of clicks form
and people that weren't in those
fraternities don't have a chance to get
in there
and so i think it's it's a very complex
issue but
the fact that it's not addressed at the
school level i think is the most
important thing and
all we're asking is that you know
somebody especially when you're bragging
about it and saying you have zero
tolerance if somebody comes to you it's
pretty clear-cut
if somebody comes to you and i described
in the book there there was a little
girl that came on from kindergarten one
you know
kindergarten that looked like she'd been
15 rounds in the ring with mike tyson
and her mother naturally wanted an
explanation well the school said she
fell
yeah and the girl said no this little
girl's but this other girl's been
picking on me and she pushed me off the
slide so
you know if that's happening in
kindergarten and somebody's covering up
i i don't even know what that
explanation is but certainly
they need to look at the teachers
through the first line of defense here
there's the first person
the first people that could
theoretically stop it yeah and
and the principals who aren't backing
them up and then the superintendents and
i describe
many many cases over and over again that
you know the readers heads will swim
looking at him but
it's always the same story when over and
over and over again
they did nothing about it uh in worst
case scenarios
my child kills himself afterwards they
continue to demonize
they infer maybe it was us you know the
family you know or you know that maybe
you were a fault
and they still don't claim any
responsibilities so it's it's a huge
issue
and uh in the limited time we have left
on when we look at
uh some of the behavior we've seen from
donald trump which includes certainly
bullying people on social media and and
directing ire at specific individuals
the irony of melania's anti-bullying
campaign while the behavior of her
husband is is completely antithetical to
that
we've since learned about some of some
elements of donald trump's upbringing
including that
his dad uh at minimum was verbally
abusive
um that you know there was this attitude
of never apologize for anything never
admit that you're wrong we
which we've seen donald trump take up
what do you make of all of that because
as you said it's not always as simple as
oh
the bully is a bully because they're
getting bullied at home
but what do you make of the trump story
well
that could have played into part there
and it could just be again he comes from
great wealth is my friend gerald celente
likes to say he was born in third base
and thinks he hit a home run there's
right there's so many
and so many of these guys do that so he
somebody like
trump led a life of privilege his entire
life he was born to the silver spoon in
his mouth
so there was it's hard to be humble
under those circumstances now in his
case he appears to have had a
very weird family dynamic his mother was
i think
probably just as strange as his father
if he's you know
and uh so i don't know i think somebody
said once that
uh nobody had ever told him that they
loved him in his life
and certainly if you look away he kind
of trades in supermodel wives every 20
years
i don't think he's ever really looked
for love he's looking for a new model so
i think he's he's
kind of the quintessential superficial
guy
the ultimate materialist guy and his
personality unfortunately
is perfect for our uh burgeoning
idiocracy that we have now
i mean he's basically in many ways he's
like president camacho if you've seen
the movie
idiocracy i mean he's got the wwe
personality
and he has what has happened is he has
lowered the level of discourse and
everybody has joined him it's a huge
food fight so you have the other side
tries to bully him and they're always
down in the gutter
they're calling each other names and
that's that's what it's turned into and
it's a
it's a shame but it's not surprising
because uh you know people
knowing of the trump's personality has
been out there for a long time
yeah listen to some of the interviews
with howard stern and stuff he's
he's really what was different is the
populist rhetoric
that a lot of us were attracted to
during his campaign i mean that was came
out of nowhere
yeah you know but no uh but the his
personality is but it's always been
packaged in that personality and
and i think because he is really
attacked constantly and if he had a
any kind of a sympathetic personality i
think a lot of people would feel sorry
for
him because he is a tech but he just
doesn't have any of that and he laughs
and uh it's unfortunate that that's you
know i wrote a whole
little section in bulliocracy uh about
the emergence of trump and uh it's
it's fitting and you're certainly like
you said his wife has an anti-bullying
message but we see that
a lot of the football players will put
people like uh russell wilson of the
seahawks who admits
what a big bully he was in school you
know he says yeah i used to rub kid's
nose in the dirt and stuff
and he runs an anti-bullying
organization now maybe he's reformed and
a lot of these football players
are in charge or sponsor these
organizations and my contention is that
football especially
breeds this bullying because it's you
know it's manliness and toughness and
you know if you're going against a uh
you know you're just natural if you're
coming up against the theater crowd
which you know may have gays in it or
whatever just very not macho guys or
whatever it's it's going to be natural
for those football players to come up
and bump against them and just you know
do what they do and it's it's it but
it's because the the
schools place so much more emphasis on
sports
than they do in academics or anything
else and we see in society
the role that sports plays in our lives
and sports plays a tremendous
amount look at all the money that that
goes into it what the corporate welfare
that i talked about in survival the
richest
the the most egregious example of that
are all the stadiums that taxpayers
build
nfl stadiums especially in mlb stadiums
that are paid for completely
and it's because the those fan that fan
base says no please don't move our team
right we'll pay for it and so i think
it's it's uh but again people don't they
don't want to equate
sports with bowling because i mean i'm a
huge sports fan i played sports i
coached sports i love sports but
i recognize how it breeds
this kind of behavior especially when
it's not held into account
yeah and to be clear there were gay
football players as well uh
that not that you were suggesting that
uh that that they're not
of course the latest book is bulliocracy
we've been speaking with
donald jeffries um don always great
speaking to you i appreciate your
time oh thanks so much for having me
dave it's a pleasure